but we begin with dangerous heat fueling
devastating wildfires across 15 states
in California a fast-moving fire has
exploded in size near Yosemite National
Park thousands have been forced to
evacuate and millions are facing air
quality alerts more than 100 miles away
Jonathan vigilat Vigliotti is at
Mariposa County where thousands of
firefighters have been working through
the night battling the massive fire
Jonathan good morning
good morning to you cooler temperatures
this morning have really helped Tamp
down these Flames but those temperatures
are expected to spike back up to 100
degrees later today that weather helped
the oak fire triple in size over the
weekend this morning it is zero percent
contained
an explosive fire just outside Yosemite
National Park is burning out of control
this morning scorching more than 15 000
Acres over the weekend
50-foot walls of flames have damaged or
completely destroyed at least 15
structures with thousands more homes and
businesses under threat
more than 6 000 residents have been
evacuated while many communities have
lost power smoke from the fire which can
be seen from the International Space
Station has prompted an air quality
advisory for the San Francisco Bay area
and this is what fighting this fire
requires helicopters have been coming to
the few water sources in the area and
dropping their Hall on this glaze fueled
by bone dry vegetation and dead trees
the fire was sparked Friday near the
Mariposa County Town of midpines we're
gonna have to rename our town I mean the
Pines probably aren't going to make it
Beth Pratt is a regional executive
director for the National Wildlife
Federation and a midpines resident The
Oaks are going Oaks are extremely you
know adapted to Drought if those guys
are going you know you're in trouble in
2021 the USDA conducted an aerial survey
and found 9.5 million trees were
standing dead in the state more than 200
000 in Mariposa County alone
scientists say most were killed by the
Western drought and Beetle infestation
linked to climate change the Towering
Flames they now feed are in some cases
impossible to reach by foot
we're the top priority fire in the state
right now this year firefighters in
California have been dispatched to more
than 4 000 wildfires and the oak fire is
so far the state's largest the fire
cycle up here before these 1500 year
droughts which were in was like a big
one every 15 20 years now we have
multiple big fires every year it's
terrifying it's it's absolutely
terrifying
terrifying and also unpredictable
scientists say climate change has fueled
the kinds of mega fires that defy all
traditional Wildfire Behavior case in
point several Wildfire Crews were
trapped by fire this weekend they had a
call for emergency backup all operations
were suspended Gail in the end they made
it out alive
Jonathan Vigliotti we thank you those
pictures very intense looks like
something out of a movie